but there is something dedicated, it has been located in the
desert for
more than 400 years, the
grapes have been grown, the wines and the
spirit called pisco are produced. Over
time,
my job has always involved my
sentimental life a lot because when I
prepare a pisco sour I  It reminds
my father
my name is Roberto Meléndez known
as Captain Meléndez and I can tell you
that I prepare the best pisco sour in
Puerto Pico Palo Meléndez it is part of
our life I learned from my father I
learned to recognize aromas and flavors in
Peru  400 years ago we distilled pisco
now and very good quality pisco and
we have almost 500 wineries that
have a designation of origin
my name is jose jose moquillaza everyone
calls me pepe pepe moquillaza I am a
narrator of liquid stories as such
I make pisco in the valley of  ica in
perico sensorially it is the purest
expression of the grape with the earth but
emotionally it is a drink of the soul I
started to make pisco because I was born in
ica every child and who does not dream of having
his own peak
how to appreciate a pisco you have to use it  the
senses look for
cleanliness, brightness and density when
you bring it to your nose you feel the
fruit above the alcohol and a few
touches of sweet hints of earth that are
when you don't taste it it should be a
very small sip
and  When you pass it, you should feel opening, a
soft touch, a touch of alcohol with
a lot of fruit and a very long persistence.
These three previous steps make the
treasury communicate here with your heart
like the great historical drinks of the
world, champagne Corto, sherry, tequila,
these drinks have a
geographical delimitation and an ancestral process that is
preserved for centuries peak follows the
same path
is something very beautiful to show the world
our culture through a distillate
pisco is the distillate that represents us
day to day and I learned it from that school and
at school  Inherited by my
father,
pisco was with the Peruvian people throughout
history, it has witnessed all their
greatness, all their hopes,
pisco has always been there.